[Music]
my name is thomas piero and i'm a
research scientist at instead i will be
leading the the new team
here in boston we're coming to boston
because it's the perfect place for
research and especially for our playing
research into real life applications
within using artificial intelligence a
lot of different verticals i'm focusing
a lot on biology and we're trying to use
artificial intelligence to learn to
understand life so mainly we're working
on proteins and also on dna and we're
really trying to see through this deep
neural network we can learn
representations we can learn what's
inside for instance a genome of a person
or a sequence of protein or a structure
and we are coming here in boston because
first there are a lot of teams doing
that at mit but there are also a lot of
pharma companies you can see also other
artificial intelligence players we're
also working with google
orgo is great for our a very good team
and also to strengthen our collaboration
with existing players for instance there
is bayern tech and we're already working
with their team in boston we really have
this period where there's not one office
just dedicated to one task we always try
to get other people to work together so
if you instance you work in a research
project in paris you will be working
with people from the uk we'll be also
working with people from tunisia from
south africa and and hopefully in the
future with people from the us i think
we can really feel in cambridge all
these people that are thinking you can
see that a lot of stuff that is
happening a lot of startups everywhere i
mean there's a lot of innovation we can
feel a bit those things moving
[Music]